am i screwed if I'm not a people person
a lot of entrepreneurs write in to me
and they have these preconceived notions
on the type of personality that you need
to have to be a success in the world of
business and for the most part it's not
true you don't have to be a people
person to have success you don't have to
be good-looking you don't have to be a
certain age you don't have to be from a
certain background or speak a certain
language none of that stuff matters it's
all in your head and so the question I
got from one of my readers Anton was a
new newsletter subscriber on my list
wrote in and he has his long story
basically had a failed business and he
was talking about my story and how I
found mentors and how they helped me and
he's worried that because he's not a
people person that he's not going to
achieve success and whether this is for
him or not so I have an entrepreneur
mindset test for me it's more about your
mindset than your personality because if
you look at successful entrepreneurs
they're from all walks of life you have
some entre NORs who are the type-a
personalities are always talking these
are the guys you see on camera all the
time and doing big stunts and you got
the ones who are shy and you're
occlusive and hate people and don't like
being in the spotlight it might be asses
to write these are successful
entrepreneurs as well and you don't have
to only look at one type and say I'm not
that person so I won't be successful in
my entrepreneur mindset test there are
hundred questions that you have to
answer that gear you towards seeing if
you're going to be a successful
entrepreneur or not and they don't
relate to personality they don't relate
to things like are you outgoing right
that doesn't matter for your successes
entreprenuer using your skills properly
so here's an example from my background
okay I am NOT I'm not the biggest people
person okay I'm not uncomfortable
talking to people but it's not my my
default okay when I go to an event I'm
not
I'm not handing up my business cards and
shaking hands and telling people here's
what I do go check out my website when I
get on an airplane
I'm not chatting with the person next to
me and and learning about them I keep to
myself for the most part and if I was in
a sales type of role that would hurt me
and I've had to discover that for my
business to be successful I had to lean
more towards the marketing and so I
create an environment where people want
to talk to me and where people want to
do business with me instead of me having
to go out and talk to them because if
that was how I built my business I
wouldn't be successful I'd be struggling
and so you have to understand what your
personality is and then design your
business around something that will
leverage your strengths just like
whatever skills you have you know if I
try to start a pizza making business it
would suck because I don't know anything
about pizza I don't know how to make
pizza I'm not a baker I don't know any
of that stuff so it would suck but if I
did something more towards my skills I'd
have a much higher degree of success and
so just like when you're thinking about
businesses start when you're thinking
about how you're going to market and how
you're going to be successful you want
to design the task that you're working
on around your personality that fits you
because I guarantee you if you are going
out thinking that I have to have I have
to have a solid team of mentors and I
have to have a big social network for me
to be successful that's your mindset and
you're not that kind of person to go out
and do it then you're not going to be
successful other people will go out and
do that and the people who you might see
on TV who are you know they like being
on camera and who are those type-a
personalities those people they're good
at those things and so they leverage
them but they suck at other stuff but
they've designed their business around
their personality and they make it work
for them this is important so no you
don't have to be a people person but you
have to do something you have to take
action around something that you're
really good at and you really enjoy
doing and you
have to have the entrepreneurs mindset
believe but those are you watching you
like the video give it a thumbs up below
if you have a question you have a
comment leave it below I'll make a video
response for you those comments mean the
world to me if you've never left a
comment yet on the video today is your
chance and then please leave a comment
thank you so much and I'll see you soon